endlich party aber bitte mit abstand nur
wenige klubs wagen es unter diesen
bedingungen auch theater dürfen wieder
spielen mit shops auflage die kultur ist
sinne im zwiespalt öffnen mit verlusten
oder noch abwarten
kulturplatz schaut sich um
[Musik]
si
viel spaß
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz ja viel
ist dieser tage zu hören über die
polizeigewalt in den usa die vereinigten
staaten sind von der pandemie des
rassismus nachhaltig befallen
dazu später bei uns ein schwerpunkt aber
zuerst etwas erfreuliches endlich gehen
die kinos theater die klubs wieder auf
und wir machen heute station hoch über
der stadt zürich hier im theater
rigiblick wie der probebetrieb mit
akuter sports gefahr funktioniert und
was hier als erstes auf die bühne kommt
das frage ich gleich den chef des hauses
[Musik]
sid
jetzt dürfen sie wieder kinos theater
clubs öffnen ihre türen aber etliche die
wollen gar nicht die krone maßnahmen
würden einen rentablen betrieb
verunmöglichen heisst es mancherorts
hier am zürcher theater rigiblick wird
jedenfalls bereits wieder gespielt dazu
gleich mehr zuerst aber ein blick nach
basel wo anteil der partyszene einen
neustart wagt letzten freitag
vorbereitungen im club mix nach der
lange lange lange krise ist froh drum
müssen mehr als happy das machen wir
jetzt einfach alle zusammen halten ein
bisschen doch in der heimat wir sind das
team bemüht sich weitgehend damit man
auch spaß haben denn eigentlich hinter
gitter bisher gab zum ersten großen
blumentopf
viele klubs bleiben trotz corona
lockerungen geschlossen
aus wirtschaftlichen gründen andere
wagen ist sehr gut es geht hier neu bist
ist verdienen aber wichtig war dass ich
im moment ist das widerlager auf auslage
und da irgendwie eingang finden wieder
normalität und in den alltag und sagte
mama karten gewusst wie viel aufwand das
er sehe ich mache das einfach auch die
heimat hat genug vom lockdown frust so
vorrangig auf 1 meter koordinatensystem
ortsbilder mit reflektiven bank und zwar
so dass jeder modernste jedes teams
welche befindet quadratmeter für sich
kein anspruch nehmen darf weiß wie noch
im augenblick können die distanz beim
tanzen kehrt schnell vergessen
die heimat bietet orientierung und sorgt
für limitierung ich finde ich hat liam
dafür bisschen drei oder vier aufmachen
und für iphone und co wirklich mit ihrer
was man sowieso machen mädchens nicht
wann der flug nicht vorher sicherheit
partyvergnügen und wirtschaftlichkeit
eine herausforderung
die korona vorschriften verwirren was
geht was geht nicht und grund vor freude
am fest steht dass glück meint an das
kontakt tracing dass das denn eigentlich
der mindestabstand regelsätze und das
ist nicht der fall sondern es ist wenn
immer möglich sollten zwei meter rekord
erwartet der die stumpf regel letzten
samstag im club an ex wiedereröffnung
bereits am nachmittag unter strengen
corona maßnahmen die der kanton
jederzeit kontrollieren kann sondern
checkliste aufgrund von branche
schutzkonzept wo man den punkt für punkt
oder grün wenn es ethisch denn an so
wäre 20 stunden zieht das ortsbild
korrigieren der gynäkologe paradox
nachtschwärmer die schon bei tageslicht
eintrudeln einlass prozedere zu coruna
zeiten
das risiko ist spürbar und es gibt
ungereimtheiten
[Musik]
die höhe schießen
wer kommt muss fahren
trotzdem die sehnsucht ist groß reggae
grooves und party lassen den carola
bluhm step by step etwas verblassten
[Musik]
internet streams machen und von dauer
ist eine langsam zurück horse ich noch
nicht so wichtig der dancefloor füllt
sich auch in der heimat
get the party started ist der ständige
soundtrack zur wiedereröffnung
wichtig ist ich habe andere siege macht
ausmaß und boden so begrenzt die
schicken
ja eigentlich begrenzung statt
ausgelassener entgrenzung
dieser status und 12 aber die party
kings und dancing queens zurück doch
auch wenn die plattenteller wieder
glühen das disco licht wieder flackert
clubbing zu corinna zeiten ist mir eine
herzensangelegenheit und seine
rauschende partynacht mach dass du türe
zu und alexander spitz landgang
christoph wirtschaft nur noch die tore
dass man trotzdem die blöden abstand die
guten abschneiden die gruppe tritt heute
zum ersten mal unter ihrem neuen namen
auf die comedian harmonists mein kleiner
grüner kaktus steht draußen ankommt
euro was brauche ich rote rosen häufig
roten
und es endlich wieder los tagen theater
rigiblick der chef von joost an ihr ohr
gelegt los erfahrungs widerruf aber via
dann überhaupt hertha mit distanz mit
proben das stück wo man eigentlich sein
will muss man das spiel zu spiel hand
thema 20 jahre und mit probiert nicht
vor heißt comedian harmonists aus mir
spiele die geschichte von einer
berühmten comedian harmonists nach und
während zieht von gronau habe ich mir
natürlich gedanken gemacht wie ich habe
nicht mit dem studium gar normaler wie
es mir das ganz normal halt inszenieren
schauspieler wird interagieren
es ist schlicht was ich erzählt albert
eckstein so das heißt im schlimmsten
fall die schauspieler nur die stühle mit
zwei meter abstand auf das rahmen
natürlich nötig war natürlich spiele
aber war man sich beim spielt er komme
sich nach x raid ludmann sports team
sind genau wie handelt das wir lösen das
anträgen der visier der schluss
situation waren die comedian harmonists
auseinander und wellstream jüdische
mitglieder karten nötig die ski und sie
sind ein aufdruck vom naziregime
auseinandergegangen
da wird das sehr wichtig in einer
situation wenn man sich wirklich habe
man jetzt wieder unter druck machen er
wirklich das oben aber druck und das ist
ganz bitter und es hat uns allen hier
lösen das ist garantiert dass er
wiederum das blut nur das braucht viel
engagement braucht subventionen vorüber
sei mit der mieter überhaupt anders
machen
ich finde dass wir werden in corona sehr
gut unterstützt wurde sind mehr anträge
auf kurzarbeit das ist wirklich sehr
sehr viel wert es braucht jetzt sehr
viel mut für das projekt vom ritz
vorhand das kann man nicht mit
subventionen machen da braucht man etwa
unterstützen wir haben jetzt aber eine
äußere spuren so
ich meine zähne wo es hapert aber ich
glaube es ist sehr wichtig dass man fürs
publikum da sind und das ist mir sehr
wichtig dass grün strich bis zur hand
das sind alles familienmitglieder sind
alles freunde
ich werde das die beschäftige ziel und
dank corona hat ganz neue idee kann man
sie aus cottbus sein
zugleich folge unter dem schönen ortes
opernball zeit stattfinden mit viel
humor was zeigen und mir hat es große
rückt das man halt
es wird bei zwei herren dass man einfach
vorstellen hand wo man schon durch max
immer wieder spielen sie brauchen ja und
aus der heimat zu bauen
die haben gute zeigen dass sehr viele
priester aber nach entstand weder
knaller ohne große vorbereitet das ist
großes glück und wie funktioniert das
dann dynamischer zuschauer dass man
krank muss man sich also machen sie auch
stadt uster webseiten gibt werden sich
wohl fühlen wenn sie sehen dass man es
im saal sind und wir haben damals das
jetzt mit uns sehr stolz auf dem platz
das heißt mitgliedern zählen und das
machen wir dann verrechnet
ich spiele wenn sie zwischen wird man
natürlich nicht spielen aber das ist wie
im open air kino oder wie in thun gc
spieler und hat bevor straße und
dienstag gespielt wird passen und
westlichen raum schlag machen vielleicht
sie auf die bühne betrat jetzt wirklich
wii erscheinen wird
es gibt ganz viel musik das gehör nach
was denn für sie der summe die momente
hinter für mich sehe noch john lennon
will mit dem herbst werde man auch schon
john lennon macht er lernen wäre jetzt
an die von dem jahr also im oktober
werden im dezember sind wir jetzt gehöre
dass er verschossen worden ich bin ganz
intensiv von john lennon das ist
natürlich eine figur und michael lang
begleitet
da hat mich berührt ich sehe das absolut
lieblingslied des herzens liegt
natürlich auf das ganz große das wäre
aber auch dass dazu
[Musik]
wir richten den blick in die usa für
unseren schwerpunkt die welt ist empört
über die polizeirepression in den
vereinigten staaten nur unsere empörung
und auch die gewalt das ist nichts neues
das ist allerdings nach dem tod von
george floyd zu einer internationalen
protestbewegung kommt das ist neu und
das ist bewegend
proteste seit mehr als zwei wochen seit
diesen acht minuten und 43 sekunden und
diesem hilferuf
ich kann nicht atmen
der protest wurde zur massenbewegung
weltweit was steckt hinter dieser
eruption
[Musik]
was bedeutet dieser tod
das fragen wir den prominenten
analytiker der us zeitgeschichte george
packer den autor und ehemaligen bleibt
aktivisten jim orr josef und den
stanford professor hans ulrich gumbrecht
die bilder von dieser ermordung und ich
nenne es bewusst ermordete sind
besonders eindrucksvoll aber halt vor
allem deswegen weil es so lange dauert
ja achteinhalb minuten von den ganz
gewiss nachdem der george wright
ohnmächtig geworden ist die zweite
hälfte ja sozusagen ein lange
ausgehalten akte ermordung sind der
filmemacher spike lee hat in einem
kurzfilm auf cnn die vielleicht
wichtigste frage gestellt wird die
geschichte aufhören sich zu wiederholen
er montiert momente des videos von
george floyd mit szenen aus seinem film
the right thing und führt dem ein
weiteres video hinzu das dokumentiert
wie 2014 eric bana zu tode kommt
ebenfalls durch polizisten
[Applaus]
das ist die geschichte wieder und wieder
das ist nicht neu seit 400 jahren werden
wir getötet tod durch einen würgegriff
sein film fokussiert auf diese metapher
auf die verwundbarkeit des nackens auf
das gebrochene genick
das genick steht symbolisch für die
schlinge für die ketten um den hals der
sklaven und gefangenen toni morrison
schreibt in ihrem buch bild hört man
volk sie können nicht ausstehen sie
können es nicht ertragen euren hals ohne
schlange zusammen es ist wirklich ein
symbol der unterdrückung george freund
tot war nicht irgendein tot er starb an
einem würgegriff einer metapher für
gewalt und inbesitznahme einem symbol
für die beziehung der amerikanischen
polizei zur afroamerikanischen
bevölkerung
[Musik]
die beziehung zwischen der polizei und
der armen schwarzen bevölkerung in den
städten ist seit jahren und jahrzehnten
voller konflikte und gewalt und die
beziehung zwischen der polizei und den
schwarzen im allgemeinen ist über die
gesamte geschichte dieses landes eine
der kontrolle der sozialen kontrolle
keine dienende oder schützen
das reicht weit zurück
denn als die sklaverei 1865 abgeschafft
wurde fehlten plötzlich hunderttausende
von arbeitskräften
doch die verfassung der usa schafft die
sklaverei zwar ab lässt aber eine
entscheidende hintertür offen
verurteilte straftäter dürfen für
zwangsarbeiten vermietet werden
und das sind meist ehemalige sklaven und
deren nachkommen bis heute ein sklave
konnte seine freiheit bekommen und wurde
dann sehr leicht wegen eines kleinen
vergehens wieder in ketten gelegt für
weitere zehn jahren so ist es geschehen
heute sind die gefängnisse in den usa so
voll wie in keiner anderen demokratie
der welt
eine teilweise privatisierte gefängnis
industrie mit hauptsächlich afro
amerikanischen arbeitern
viele unternehmen machen geschäfte mit
gefängnissen und verdienen milliarden
dollar
ich spreche von bekleidungs und
telekommunikationsunternehmen
als ich im bundesgefängnis saß gab es da
fabriken die t shirts und unterwäsche
für das militär herstellten und
postsäcke sie begannen mit der
herstellung von glasfaserkabeln für die
telekommunikation
es gab ganze call center
die polizei ist den privat unterhaltenen
gefängnissen der gefängnisse industrie
verpflichtet jedes jahr eine bestimmte
quote von häftlingen zu liefern
das ist natürlich drastisch das muss man
sich vorstellen das ist ganz furchtbar
und es wird auch nach amerikanischem
recht sehr schwierig sein diese verträge
zu unterbinden
das gefängnissystem ist nur eine form
des strukturellen rassismus des
würgegriff diskriminierung mit vielen
die luft dagegen richtet sich dieser
protest der vielleicht zu einer neuen
bürgerrechtsbewegung führen wird
dann wäre der memorial day 2020 der tag
an dem george freund ermordet wurde ein
historischer tag
und der protest ein aufbruch die frage
ist was wird nun entstehen wird es eine
zweite welle der pandemie könnten wird
es eine echte reform der polizei geben
wird sich die bewegung einfach auflösen
das sind für mich die großen fragen wenn
es den fortschritt gäbe dass man sagen
könnte der polizei würgegriff den gibt
es nicht mehr und polizisten wären
anders rekrutiert als vorher und anders
ausgebildet als vorher
und wenn man sagen würde wir beginnen
uns auf die umstrukturierung der krisen
industrie zu konzentrieren
dann könnte man sich vielleicht auf
diese memorial day 2020 eines tages
positiv beziehen
[Musik]
wir bleiben in den usa und stellen ihn
aus aktuellem anlass das werk des
amerikanischen schriftstellers thomas
mann vor in seinen kriminalromanen
zeigte auf welche zwickmühle
afroamerikaner unter weiße vorherrschaft
kommen können
seine romane basieren auf wahren
begebenheiten und sind aktueller denn je
die ersten schwarzen us polizisten acht
werden 1948 in atlanta georgia vereidigt
sie vertreten das gesetz und das mitten
im ethnischen minenfeld der südstaaten
sie sind bürger zweiter klasse und
gleichzeitig autoritäts figur ein
enormer konflikt ihre existenz ist eine
provokation für weiße rassisten
jeder tag kann der letzte sein mehrfach
wird versucht sie zu überfahren
atlanta 70 jahre später amerikas brodeln
der süden martin luther kings heimat
keimzelle des widerstands thomas mann
hat über die ersten afro-amerikanischen
polizisten der stadt zwei kriminalroman
geschrieben
der dritte erscheint dieses jahr
in diesem haus waren die schwarzen
beamten untergebracht im keller das
polizeirevier ihrer weißen kollegen
durften sie nicht betreten
das war enorm demütigen für sie für die
weißen befürworter der rassentrennung
aber damals ganz normal
ich habe mich gewundert wie die
schwarzen kopf ist das ausgehalten haben
was für einen effekt dass auf ihre
psyche gehabt haben muss man geht der
frage in seinen büchern nach
kontrollieren dürfen die polizisten nur
andere schwarze nicht die weißen
arbeiten dürfen sie nur nach
sonnenuntergang und nur zu fuß jede
nacht patrouillieren sie im viertel in
dem wenig später martin luther king
pfarrer wird
in den romanen taucht sein vater
ebenfalls pastor als randfigur auf
jackson smith ein nachbar und freund der
kings saß damals als kleiner junge in
den kirchenbänken und tut es heute noch
in den 40ern isis schwarz und weise
während sap red dot eco getrennt aber
gleichwertig von wegen
getrennte aber gleich waren wir nicht
wir durften im bus nur hinten sitzen
dürften ihm viele restaurants nicht
gehen und die polizei hat uns
unterdrückt das ist der heute noch immer
an vielen orten so aber damals geschah
es völlig ungeniert geschätzt jeder
vierte polizist war mitglied des
ku-klux-klan doch etwas beginnt sich zu
ändern
gerade hatten viele afroamerikaner im
zweiten weltkrieg für ihr land gekämpft
das musste doch etwas verändert haben
für sie in amerika für die schwarze
bevölkerung damals war klar wenn wir den
faschismus in europa bekämpfen dann
müssen wir das jetzt auch zu hause tun
als der krieg vorbei war hatten viele
große erwartungen
seine romane spiegeln amerikanische
geschichte mitte der vierziger der
supreme court erlaubt afroamerikanern
die teilnahme an vorwahlen plötzlich
wollen politiker ihre stimmen
die ersten schwarzen polizisten werden
vereidigt ein wort hatte die
stadtverwaltung noch schnell in ihre
ernennungsurkunden setzen lassen wir
waren so stolz auf sie trugen ihre
uniform hatten autorität und wir wussten
sie behandeln uns für uns war das damals
der beginn einer neuen ära
doch das zeigen die bücher ihr leben war
ein widerspruch jede nacht das gesetz
verteidigen dass sie selbst fundamental
diskriminierte tonia austin ist heute
eine ihrer nachfolgerinnen
[Musik]
ich war mir lange gar nicht bewusst wie
groß die opfer waren die sie bringen
muss
sie müssen enorm auf der hut sein jeden
tag in ihrer eigenen community wurden
sie verspottet dafür dass ihre
möglichkeiten zu begrenzt waren
die kritik an ihnen wuchs in der sie
teil des systems wurden wurden sie für
viele zu gegnern auch wir stellen uns
gerade in den usa wieder diese frage wie
kann man ein system verbessern indem er
versucht es von innen heraus zu
verändern oder glauben wir dass das
system und dann sofort vereinnahmt und
korrumpiert und wem generell fern
bleiben sollte so äußerte sich mal ein
anfang ja noch vor der letzten
eskalation in der chronologie von gewalt
an afroamerikaner
wir haben den autor der kriminalromane
noch mal per skype kontaktiert was hat
der brutale übergriff gegen george floyd
bei ihm ausgelöst
[Musik]
ich war schockiert
es ist schlicht traurig und alarmierend
dass wir diese probleme mit der
polizeigewalt noch nicht gelöst haben
die polizei ist heute aufgerüstet wie
das militär gleichzeitig muss es für
einen afroamerikanischen polizisten
extrem schwer auszuhalten sein zu sehen
wie george floyd getötet wird
sie stehen unter großem druck wollen
ihre arbeit gut machen sich korrekt
verhalten sehen aber dass viele ihrer
kolleginnen und kollegen das nicht tun
zum glück sind heute mehr polizisten und
polizeichefs bereit fehlbare öffentlich
zu kritisieren
einzelne städte in den usa sind nun
gewillt konkrete reformschritte in die
tat umzusetzen
valence romane ermöglichen dabei den
blick zurück in die geschichte und
dienen als orientierungshilfe für heute
drängende veränderungen
[Musik]
schnell
und noch ein stück von uns zu afro
amerikanischen realität soeben wurde in
der kunsthalle basel die ausstellung der
amerikanischen fotografin tina lawson
eröffnet sie spielt mit unseren
klischees vom schwarzen leben und das
kann ganz schön entlaufen sein
der alltag inszeniert zelebriert trotz
örtlicher verhältnisse und schon mag uns
die ausstellung ertappt haben wir
schauen sie vielleicht an als hätten sie
nicht genug aber in ihren augen haben
sie es geschafft zumindest bis zu einem
gewissen grad
wir sind stolz uns in ihrem zuhause
willkommen zu heißen und ihr leben mit
uns zu teilen sagt elena filipovic
direktorin der kunsthalle basel
die us-amerikanerin redet für die
nuancen die zurzeit keine interviews
gibt
stattdessen ihre bilder sprechen lässt
und so dem publikum den spiegel vorhält
[Musik]
sie spielt mit dem spiegel damit für uns
mit uns selbst auseinandersetzen müssen
die ironie dieser arbeiten ist ja dass
sie tatsächlich in spiegel gefasst sind
das hat einen doppelten effekt zum einen
sehen wir uns selbst vor den bildern zum
anderen schauen wir so auf unsere
eigenen stereotype der wahl die
fotografien das gezeigte ins würde
voller erheben wollen
etwa bei mir trotz ihres jungen alters
bereits dreifache großmutter und stolz
darauf wurde bei ihm die wand schmutzig
das sofa verschließen
doch sein königreich hier nennt er sich
und bei ihr
sie will nicht wohl leer wirken sondern
stark und dem sie sich verletzlich zeigt
nackt gibt preis was sich nicht
abstreifen lässt die fußfessel brüche
werden sichtbar
großflächig fast wie bei gemälden und
gehäuft
was diener lassen unbedingt wollte waren
ein wenig zu viele fotografien in diesem
raum die zudem etwas zu nah aufeinander
platziert sind für eine traditionelle
hängen
sie sagte mir dass sie die bilder so eng
beieinander möchte damit die
porträtierten in der lage sein sich
gegenseitig zu schätzen wenn man sich
vor augen führt was in den usa momentan
passiert wird dies umso berührender
trauriger und dadurch werden die nelsons
gedanken noch bedeutender als er
überlegte wie sie die bilder gruppieren
soll damit die menschen einst werden
fotografien des alltags die nicht
alltäglich sind
und für alle tage dokumentieren
[Musik]
spa
das war unser besuch im zürcher theater
rigiblick in der hauptrolle heute großes
engagement in schwierigen zeiten unser
thema nächste woche die art basel findet
zum ersten mal in ihrer 50-jährigen
geschichte nicht stadt jedenfalls nicht
so wie gewohnt mit großem schaulaufen
der internationalen kunst prominenz
sondern virtuell mehr dazu nächsten
mittwoch gleich jetzt folgt die
britische tv serie bodyguard kommen sie
gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]